[Música]
el presidente de donald trump salió
caminando del hospital militar de
maryland en el que estaba ingresado por
kobe 19 no tengan miedo al coronavirus
dijo el mandatario en twitter y anunció
que volvería pronto a la campaña
electoral
la secretaria de prensa que la imaginé y
ni se sumó a una lista cada vez más
larga de colaboradores de la casa blanca
y de republicanos de alto rango cercanos
al presidente trump que han contraído el
cob y 19 tenemos reporte con nuestra
corresponsal en washington y analizamos
también en esta emisión
varios retoma las medidas para
contenerla cada vez más elevada de
incidencia de casos de coronavirus a
partir del martes se cierran bares
piscinas y gimnasios y se reduce el
aforo en universidades cines museos y
centros comerciales tenemos reporte
desde la capital francesa
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria a 29 días de las elecciones
estadounidenses el presidente de donald
trump salió del hospital militar donde
se encontraba internado por kobe 19 y ya
llegó a la casa blanca el mandatario
estadounidense había hecho un anuncio en
twitter antes de su equipo médico en el
que decía me siento muy bien no tengan
miedo al cob y 19 a pesar de que eeuu es
el país con más contagios de esta
pandemia con más de 7 millones y más de
210.000 personas han muerto trump
seguirá recuperándose en la casa blanca
más temprano sus médicos habían
informado que se recuperaba
satisfactoriamente pero que no estaba
aún fuera de peligro
en las últimas 24 horas el presidente
sigue mejorando ha cumplido o excedido
todos los criterios para una alta médica
hoy recibió una dosis de recibir y ahora
planeamos llevarlo a casa han pasado más
de 72 horas desde su última fiebre los
niveles de oxígeno incluyendo la
saturación ambulatoria y su respiración
están todas normales aunque no ha salido
en su totalidad del peligro el equipo y
yo acordamos que nuestras evaluaciones y
lo más importante su estatus apoyan el
regreso del presidente a su hogar donde
estará rodeado de un cuidado de médicos
de renombre mundial durante 24 horas con
y forzar enlazamos a washington con
nuestra corresponsal diana castañeda
diana te saludamos por ahí en la capital
estadounidense el presidente ya llegó a
la casa blanca donde terminara su
recuperación se sabe si seguirá
trabajando si retomará funciones de
inmediato y que sabemos de la primera
dama
así es el presidente de donald trump
continuará con sus funciones desde que
se trasladó desde la casa blanca al
hospital walter y también tenía en esta
digamos su habitación presidencial una
oficina en donde continuó trabajando
contigo hablando con senadores en el
congreso republicanos y se espera que el
presidente continúe con sus actividades
de hecho este mensaje que envió hacía
referencia a lo mismo asegurando que no
se debía tener miedo al virus que se
tenía que regresar a sus funciones y que
también quería agradecer a las personas
que habían estado siguiendo su salud
permanentemente y vimos como el
presidente salió caminando afuera del
hospital y después fue trasladado a la
casa blanca hasta el momento el personal
médico no ha confirmado por cuánto
tiempo estará la primera dama en el
hospital quien no acompañó al presidente
pero lo cierto es que el personal médico
de walter y al igual que el médico
personal del presidente aseguraron que
no hay ninguna razón que indique en su
estado de salud que no puede continuar
los cuidados desde la casa blanca diana
y antes de salir el mandatario envió un
mensaje en twitter diciendo que no le
tengan miedo al coronavirus es que no
cambiará su postura pese a que eeuu es
el país más afectado del mundo
como lo mencionas esto ha generado
muchísimas críticas por parte incluso de
los demócratas al interior del congreso
y justo hace una hora el candidato
demócrata también a la presidencia yo
bailé le pidió al mandatario que apruebe
que dé respaldo a un mandato nacional
para el uso de la máscara para la
luchada y protección de los ciudadanos y
este es un debate que se ha dado al
interior de muchos estados donde
gobernadores republicanos están luchando
para que las personas no utilicen la
máscara y no sea un mandato como tal de
la luz pública así que vemos una
contradicción entre lo que está haciendo
el presidente y lo que dice en su
política muy bien diana castañeda muchas
gracias por tu reporte desde washington
y es que el brote de kobe 19 dentro de
la casa blanca se expande con el
contagio ahora de la secretaria de
prensa que la imagen eine quien anunció
hoy que había dado positivo por kobe 19
como nos decía a diana nuestra
corresponsal tanto el presidente como
los funcionarios de su gobierno han
recibido críticas por haber violado en
múltiples ocasiones las normas de
seguridad pautadas como el uso de
máscaras
así el distanciamiento social
especialmente durante la ceremonia de
nominación de nikon y barrett como
magistrada de la corte suprema y es que
miren la lista de personas que fueron
ese día y que están contagiadas van en
aumento
hoy el positivo de mccain y se suma al
de donald trump su esposa melanie a su
ex asesora que elián conway tres
senadores republicanos entre otros de
sus allegados como su asesor a hope
hicks o el jefe de campaña vil este pin
es por ello que nos comunicamos con
lawrence winner urgell es analista
político y constructor internacional
también ex diplomático estadounidense
señor gum binner gracias por esta
comunicación es una estrategia política
esta salida tan rápida de donald trump
del hospital
bueno les es muy difícil decir en este
momento cuánto de esto ha sido un 70 y
médico y cuánto ha sido un incidente
político lo que es claro es que este va
a tener un gran impacto en la campaña
que falta apenas un mes para terminar
antes de salir lo mencionábamos el
mandatario envió un mensaje en twitter
diciendo que no tengan miedo al cob y 19
esto hace que se fortalezca de cara a
las elecciones del próximo noviembre
tras esta enfermedad
puede tener un aspecto positivo y
negativo para el presidente por el lado
positivo él está tratando de mostrar su
carácter fuerte que él puede recuperar
rápidamente a esta enfermedad tan serio
y quiere compararlo con lo que él está
tratando de pintar
como alguien viejo y débil pero por otro
lado es claro que el público
estadounidense no está contento con el
liderazgo del presidente trump con la
pandemia entonces mientras la pandemia
está en los titulares eso es un negativo
políticamente para donoso el presidente
quiere enfocar en la economía quiere
enfocar la batalla para la corte suprema
quiere enfocar las las protestas en las
calles que son violentos pero no quiere
que el coaching sea el tema principal
mientras el cobre domina los titulares
está en peligro la presidencia de la
campaña de chrome muy bien logró un
minero muchas gracias por esta
comunicación por sus palabras
analista político o consultor
internacional también ex diplomático
estadounidense ahora hablemos de otras
ciudades europeas y también
estadounidenses porque las autoridades
de grandes urbes como parís y nueva york
empiezan a retomar las medidas
restrictivas en la capital de francia
van a cerrar todos los bares a partir de
este martes una medida que perjudica
enormemente a todo un sector económico
gimnasios y piscinas tampoco podrán
abrir en qué consiste el más alto nivel
de alerta declarado en la capital
francesa nos explica natalia ruiz
parís y tres de esos departamentos
limítrofes están en alerta máxima el
virus avanza rápidamente así lo
indicaron las autoridades locales
durante una conferencia de prensa en la
que dieron a conocer las diferentes
medidas que entran en vigor a partir de
este martes y por espacio de 15 días la
principal de ellas bueno pues que los
padres tendrán que cerrar sus puertas
así como los gimnasios las salas los
salones de eventos todo tipo de fiestas
estudiantiles quedan prohibidas así como
las reuniones de más de diez personas
pública para visitar a los adultos
mayores en las residencias o ancianatos
tendrán que hacer tendrá que hacerse
solamente con la cita previa y en las
universidades allí donde se está
presentando el 30 por ciento de los
focos de contagio en la región el aforo
será máximo de 50 por ciento que se
halla en los comedores como en los
salones de clase por otra parte los
restaurantes sí podrán continuar
atendiendo público pero tendrán que
hacerlo siguiendo un protocolo sanitario
mucho más estricto los lugares como
teatros los cines los museos estos
podrán continuar con las puertas
abiertas y también los estadios con un
aforo máximo de 1000 personas esto
quiere decir que no habrá un impacto
sobre el torneo roland garros ni tampoco
sobre los partidos de fútbol y rugby
programados en los próximos días cabo
estos 15 días el 19 de octubre para ser
exactos con las autoridades revisarán
todo este paquete de medidas para saber
si las mantienen o no todo dependiendo
de que hayan mejorado los diferentes
indicadores de la epidemia
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía y los invitamos a seguir con
nosotros en plantas 24
[Música]